Good morning, John!
Today is the day after Thanksgiving here in America.
Traditionally,
the day
when we buy
all the things!
Actually, more traditionally at my house,
it's the day when we don't leave the house;
because Black Friday.. terrifies me.
For people who aren't American,
the very ominous-sounding Black Friday is an accident of history.
So, back in 1621,
it was hard livin' here in America;
and the first English settlers
had a really bountiful crop.
Apparently.
This is somewhat mythological...
And, it was on a Thursday;
and they were thankful!
That inspired a holiday;
which is a nice kind of idea for a holiday,
where you just talk about the things that you're thankful for.
And eat a bunch of food!
You also eat a bunch of food.
Until the 1860's,
different states celebrated this holiday on different days.
Until Abraham Lincoln said:
"This.. is the day! We're gonna have a national day.";
and, the South was like:
"We're not even part of you anymore.
What are you talking about?!"
But then, when we got back together again,
that was good;
and it became the national holiday.
The fourth Thursday in November.
Now, because it's a national holiday on the Thursday,
you also sort of get that Friday as a de facto day off.
'Cause you don't want to go back to work for one day
and then have the weekend;
that's just dumb!
In the '60's [1960's], because so many people were going on vacation on this day,
or, to a lesser extent, going shopping;
this became such a terrible traffic mess
that police and taxi drivers started calling it "Black Friday".
As stores,
and also just general consumerist cultures,
started pushing the idea of Christmas shopping
further and further away from Christmas;
the big block in the road,
where you can't push it back any further, is Thanksgiving.
'Cause that's its own holiday.
You can't start Christmas before Thanksgiving.
And so, Black Friday became the official tipping point
into the consumerist bonanza that is the holiday shopping season!
Despite the fact that it has kind of this ominous-sounding name,
it has been billed as the biggest and most important and best holiday shopping day of the year;
which is actually not true.
We are.. a nation of procrastinators;
and thus, the biggest shopping day of the year
is Christmas Eve.
It seems a little bit upsetting
that the day after we all get done
telling the world why we should be satisfied with our lives,
we are.. barraged with an advertising blitz
showing us all of the things that we lack!
At the same time,
it is very important to the American economy.
I mean, you can't really get angry at people
for wanting to give each other things...
And yes,
DFTBA.com has its own Black Friday and Cyber Monday deals;
and you can go to DFTBA.com and check those out now.
It's also
our 4th Anniversary of being a company,
which is very exciting!
And, to celebrate that fourth anniversary,
all shipping within the United States this weekend,
starting tomorrow,
I think,
is just $4.00!
No matter what you buy!!
But, I do think it's important that
we don't just scrub the idea of satisfaction and thankfulness out of our brains
as soon as we're done for Thanksgiving.
And so, on this Black Friday,
I want to continue being thankful.
I'm thankful to my wonderful and supportive parents;
to my beautiful, and intelligent, and hilarious wife.
I'm thankful to my new Wii U.
If you want to go to youtube.com/hankgames,
you can see us playing the new Super Mario Brothers there soon.
I'm thankful to all of my great friends here in Missoula
and across the world.
I'm thankful to finally have a robust and stable forum
that can handle the weight of Nerdfighteria.
There's a link in the description.
I'm thankful to Youtube and Google
for funding SciShow and Crash Course,
and for supporting
VlogBrothers, and all of our endeavors through the years.
I'm thankful to Reddit ,
and QI,
and Mental Floss magazine,
for making sure that I keep learning interesting things.
I'm thankful to Jonas Salk for giving away the patent to his polio vaccine to the world,
so that it could be less expensive to manufacture;
and Tim Berners-Lee for doing basically the same thing with the internet.
I'm thankful to the Nerdcrafteria Minecraft server and Tumblr, and the Ning;
and all the other places
on the internet where Nerdfighters do Nerdfighter things.
And, I'm thankful to all the wonderful, thoughtful, intelligent people
who watch and support
the things that I do on the internet;
even when it's sappy, silly videos like this one.
And I'm thankful, of course,
for my brother
who's always driving me to do new and interesting and difficult things;
and who's raising a wonderful family,
and who says wise and intelligent things on Tumblr.
And John,
I'll see you on Tuesday.
*Music plays*